gordon brown good morning to you thank
you very much for being with us here on
skype so
first of all what would be achieved by
holding daily emergency cobra meetings
well we've got um energy crisis we've
got an inflation crisis we're going to
have a national health service
waiting list crisis
what uh cobra meeting and that's the
emergency committee that we hold when
things are difficult has got to do is
ensure there's enough energy for the
winter ensure there's enough storage
facilities
ensure that
we can
get the cost of living help to people
because we've only seven weeks to go
before october the first you've got to
change the universal credit computer to
enable it to make payments to people and
there's no doubt that people are going
to go without food and they're going to
go hungry and cold in october if we
don't take action now so this is the
time to take action and that's why i'm
saying that
the government ministers should be
meeting with the two leadership
candidates so that they can agree a
package that could be implemented
immediately if not parliament should be
recalled to look at what is a national
emergency and at the same time of course
the special committee should be meeting
to look at all these plans
you know you could be looking at a cap
on energy prices you could be doing what
norway does and say we'll pay 80 of the
increase in bills or you could have that
better social security support but all
these things are not really being
discussed by government ministers at the
moment not even the leadership
candidates who are obsessed about tax
cuts we've really got to deal with this
cost of living crisis the supply of
energy shortages of storage facilities
but also deal with the cost of living
costs that people are having to pay
now they're saying that of course that
when whichever one of them takes office
comes into office they will address it
then this trust says there'll be an
emergency buzzer and richie sunak says
as oliver dad and just told us that all
measures um will be taken when necessary
why do you think that during the
campaign
more of this happen
but that's too late
yeah that's too late because you need
this time now to make decisions if
you're going to affect things on october
the 1st it takes weeks to change the
benefits system undoubtedly
we will need to pay people more money so
if you have a budget let's say in the
second week of september you might get
benefits to people before christmas
uh if you have
soon accept plan that he's going to look
at it later
then it will be too late uh the prime
minister i understand is now back from
holiday today uh the chancellor should
be there and they should be talking to
the two leadership candidates and agree
a package now if they agree as they're
now agreeing then this has started over
the weekend but there is action that has
to be taken it should not wait uh for
another month or two it should be taken
now
um what are you saying to the labour
party of course because uh as a former
prime minister mr brown up while your
words are very well respected obviously
you can't influence what the current
party is doing or can you what are you
saying to the current shadow cabinets
what do you want to see them doing
well of course they're saying that
there's an urgent crisis and
things have got to be done and they have
proposed a series of measures to deal
with the heating crisis what's happened
however which makes it urgent in the
last few weeks is that we now know that
heating bills are going to rise even
faster in october and then again in
january so we're dealing with the
severity of the crisis 15 million
households to be hit
we're also dealing with the scale of it
that some households will lose about 35
to 40 pounds a week they'll be short in
having to pay their bills and will be
unable to pay their bills and of course
we're dealing with the social
consequences children and care
homelessness mental health problems all
of which will cost money if we don't
take action to try to alleviate some of
these anxieties you know i talk to
charities in my own area here in
scotland quite a lot and they are
dreading october they are stocking up on
their duvets and sleeping bags and hot
water bottles and sheets and pillows and
blankets because they know that people
can't afford to heat their homes anymore
and the best we can hope is people
heating themselves i talk to churches
and faith groups into their great credit
they're thinking of opening their church
halls as heating hubs so that pensioners
instead of freezing at home can have a
warm place to go to now if charities
and organizations in the community are
taking urgent action to do something i
think it's about time the government
responded the vacuum at the center of
government really has got to end
i mean you made that very clear mr brown
but if if you were in downey street
right now what would you do today this
week to make a real difference to those
people facing those catastrophic bills
on the 1st of october
well the first thing i would do is call
the meeting together with the leadership
candidates because they've got to
approve what the prime minister would be
proposing i think the chancellor's got
to be back so that we do first of all we
look at what we can do to help people
pay the bills over the winter we know
that they're going to be short of
maybe up to 1500 pounds this year and
that's some of the poorest families in
the country we know that tax cuts will
not make the difference because they go
to people who have got the most money
not people who've got the least money so
i would be talking about changes in the
universal credit system to give people
the money that is necessary and i would
be talking about potentially capping
energy bills and that would have the
effect of getting inflation down
as well as of course of helping people
in the greatest need but none of these
things seem to be being discussed at the
moment in the way they should be and it
really is not good enough for leadership
candidates to go around the country say
i'll have a plan next month the month
after this is the crisis that's going to
be addressed now if we're going to help
people by the first of october so my
measures about uh changes in the benefit
system uh helping particularly families
with children and pensioners and
disabled people who've lost out from
richie sunak's previous packages
and of course uh looking at how we can
deal with the energy companies now if
you want to pay for it
i would say that the windfall tax could
raise 15 billion pounds
when the government is only proposing to
raise five billion pounds and that's
because richie sunic built in all the
opt-outs for the energy companies if
they invested more and so on and so
forth let's just get the money in
because there are excess profits that
are windfall that are not due to the
success of the companies but due to the
changes in the energy market and that's
something that they should not
necessarily benefit from but the public
should get the money instead
so change to the benefit system i took
from that you want to see an increase in
the amount that the poorest households
receive and you're going to pay for it
with another windfall tax i mean it's
hard enough getting the government to
agree to the first one another one at
this stage
no it's the same windfall tax it's just
removing all the opt-outs what richie
sunak did rather stupidly in my view was
said i'll agree with the labour party
who's proposed this winfor tax we'll put
it at 25 percent as they propose but
we'll give companies the opt-out that
they can claim all their expenses
against this tax with the result that
he's reduced the value of the tax from
15 billion
to 5 billion now 10 billion it could
give people on universal credit a huge
amount of additional money over the
winter months to be able to cope with
these heating bills you see what's
actually happened let's be clear about
this the government in many ways to the
credit have offered 1200 pounds to
families in greatest need but that's not
enough because they lost a thousand
pounds when universal credit was taking
away benefits are only going up three
percent but inflation's eleven percent
so that's roughly another thousand
pounds loss and now we've got these big
rises announced last week that are going
to happen in october and january and
heating bills and that's at least
another few hundred pounds and so
anything the government has done has
already been wiped out and they have got
to do more now other countries i look at
germany at france and spain and portugal
and norway and they're doing more than
we are doing and it's about time that
the government took action and the only
time that really matters is when you're
planning for the winter months it's too
late if you do the changes in november
or december you've got to help people in
october so they're not going hungry
and children will go to school ill-clad
and undernourished if we don't do
something about it and pensioners will
have to choose between feeding
themselves and feeding their gas and
electricity meters
and mr brown you said that we're
expecting a financial time bomb to go
off on the first of october obviously
you were in office where another
financial time bomb or not even time on
the time a bomb went off while you're in
office and you and you guided the
country or were helping the country
through that so would you like to return
to frontline politics now do you think
no i think when you're out you're out
and you've got to accept that that's
what's happened but i do feel very
strongly about this you know i i live in
the place i was brought up in in fife in
my county and i am seeing poverty that i
did not expect to see ever again in my
lifetime you know i grew up in a mining
and textiles town which went through a
long period of unemployment and now
unfortunately we're back to some of the
conditions we saw then when people uh
have not the money to turn up the
heating
when they're having uh to tell the
children they cannot give them basic
necessities when people are in charities
and you know in my uh town and county
people don't have a lot but they help
people with nothing but the people who
don't have a lot are also running out of
money and not able to help so food banks
need more help but they cannot do it on
their own charities cannot solve this
problem on their own no matter how
well-meaning they are it's really up to
the government now and in every other
country there is a recognition of this
crisis and people are acting now and
it's time for this government no matter
what's happening in the tory leadership
contest they should all get together and
see if they can agree on a program but
it's got to happen in the next few days
i want to push you a little bit on that
if i can mr brown i know important
duties to you and service and uh your
experience may well be essential at this
time so if you were asked to come back
in would you
it's not going to happen i mean
you just held oliver dowden on your
program this morning at making all sorts
of party political allegations against
me which are completely wrong of course
but i know them because what i'm
interested in is what is in the
interests of the people of this country
and i can help and i'm working with
local charities to do so but the most
important thing is that those who have
got elective power for the time being
that they take the action that is
necessary you know it's ridiculous at
the time of this crisis that the prime
minister and the chancellor have both
been on holiday the foreign secretary
and richie sunak the former chancellor
on the campaign trail and nobody seems
in charge now of course i could walk in
tomorrow and say this is what the cobra
committee should do and i'm telling you
what i think it should do but of course
i'm realistic enough to know that the
conservatives are in power and it's
their turn to take the action that is
necessary and if not make way for kia
stammer who's ready and waiting to do
good things and would you work for
secure stamina then mr brown
uh kierstama is going to be a great uh
prime minister of this uh country and i
think everybody knows he's a person of
integrity uh he's made the right uh
decisions uh to rejuvenate the labour
party and i think he is the person that
people can turn to with a great deal of
hope as well as a huge amount of trust
and would you work in a cabinet that he
set up sir
i'm not going to be invited back but
obviously i'm here to help and
i i'm uh you know too young to be an
american politician when you look at the
ages of american politicians but i know
that uh it's uh it's time for other
people to take their helm and look the
team that keostama is bringing together
is incredibly impressive and i think you
can look forward to something
in our politics that will make a radical
change in the way that we do things you
see what i find uh
amazing at the moment is there is a huge
crisis we had covered we've got
obviously to recover still from that and
the national health service also needs
uh urgent attention about how we can
avoid these winter crises and the big
waiting list but it does need the people
who are empowered to get together to do
it and you know this cannot
be happen quickly enough it's got to
happen now